PROFESSOR: All right. lecture
14 was about two main topics,
I guess.
We had slender adorned chains,
the sort of fatter linkages,
and then hinged dissection.
Most of our time was actually
spent with the slender
adornments and proving
that that works.
But most of our questions today
are about hinged dissections
because that's kind
of the most fun,
and there's a lot more
to say about them.
So first question is,
is there any software
for hinged dissections?
And the short answer
is no, surprisingly.
So this would definitely be
a cool project possibility.
There are a bunch
of examples-- let
me switch to these on the web--
just sort of random examples,
cool dissections people
thought were so neat
that they wanted
to animate them.
And so they
basically constructed
where the coordinates were over
time in Mathematica, and then
put it on the web as a
illustration of that.
So this is a
equilateral triangle
to a hexagon-- a
regular hexagon.
It's a hinged dissection
by Greg Frederickson,
and then is drawn
by have Rick Mabry.
Here's another one for
an equilateral triangle
to a pentagon.
Pretty cool.
And they're hinged in
a tree-like fashion
even, which is kind of unusual.
Greg Frederickson is one of the
masters of hinged dissections,
and dissections in general.
He's probably the master
of dissections in general.
And he has three books of
different kinds of dissections.
This is actually hinged the
section on the cover here.
The purple and pink
pieces hinge like this
into a smaller star from
the outline of a big star
to the interior
of a smaller star.
And then this star
fits nicely inside.
This is another
hinged dissection.
This book is entirely
about hinged dissections,
although not just
the kinds we've seen.
Another kind called
twist hinging,
which I think this
is a twist hinge.
The piece flips
around the other side.
And then there's the third
book about a different kind
of hinged dissection that's more
of a surface hinged dissection
where you've got two--
you've got the front
and back of this surface
and you fold them
with like piano hinges
with hinges in the plane.
All are very cool books.
You should check
them out if you want
to know more about dissections.
They're more about here are
cool examples, some design
techniques for how to make them.
I'll show you one such design
technique later on today.
but not a ton of theory here, in
particular because there wasn't
a ton of theory when
these books were written.
So that's some
hinged dissections.
And as I said,
cool project would
be to make a general tool for
animating hinged dissections.
There's only a
handful out there.
Greg has digital files of lots
of his hinged dissections.
He'd probably be
willing to share them,
though I haven't
talked to him about it.
If there was a good
engine for animating them
I think it would be cool.
Even cooler would
be to implement
the slender adorn
chain business.
Take one of these hinged
dissections, maybe they just
hinge but sometimes
there's collisions.
But we already
know if you refine
these guys to be
slender, which you
can do-- if they are
triangulated you can do it
with only losing a factor of
three in the number of pieces.
It would be cool
to implement that.
And then you can do the
slender adorned folding
via CDR, which I have
an implementation of,
or it's not that hard to build
one if you have a LP solver.
So various project
possibilities.
Another cool project
would be to just design
more hinged dissections.
There's still
interesting questions.
Either use fewer pieces or
just make elegant designs.
Related to the implementation
idea, a particular family
of hinged dissections that
could be fun to implement
are embodied by this alphabet.
I showed this in lecture.
You can take the letter six
and convert it into a square,
and convert it into an eight,
and convert it into a four,
and convert it into a
nine via these 128 pieces.
I didn't talk much about
this theorem though,
so I thought I'd give you
a little sketch of how
this works.
It's actually very simple to
construct the folded states
of these hinged
dissections, and it
could be an interesting
thing to implement.
And it's also just kind of fun.
This is way earlier,
1999, way before
we knew that everything
was possible.
We could at least do all
polyominoes of a given size.
So let's just think about
polyominoes, about polyhexes,
polyiamonds, where you
have equilateral triangles.
And these are called
polyabolos for silly reasons,
basically, by analogy
to a diablo, which
is a juggling device.
You can hinge dissect
any of them here.
You take each square and you
cut it into two half-squares,
and then you hinge them
together like this.
This Is 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
So this will make any
four-square object,
any tetris piece.
And generally, you
take two end pieces
and you can make any anomina.
And the way you prove
that that is universal,
that it can fold into
anything-- it's not
so clear from this picture,
but it's actually really easy
to prove by induction.
So the first thing to do
in this inductive proof
is to check that you can
do it for n equals 1.
OK.
That may sound trivial
but this is actually core.
The key property you need
in a hinged dissection
of a single square into
your general family
is that there's a hinge visible
on every edge of the object.
So here, this hinge kind
of covers this edge,
it covers that edge.
So both of these edges
have hinges on them,
and the other two edges
have a hinge on them.
They happen to be shared
hinges but that's OK.
And each of these, that's true.
The triangle, it's a
little more awkward.
You actually need two hinges
to cover the three sides.
But you only need
these two pieces.
One of them is non-convex.
It may be hard to
fold continuously
but you'd refine
it if you wanted
to do slender adornments.
So let's not worry about
continuous motion yet.
So that's the base
case of the induction.
How do I do it for n equals 1?
Now inductively, if
I have some shape
I want to build I'll
take what I call
the dual graph of that shape.
So make a vertex
for every square,
connect them together
if they share
an edge-- the squares
share an edge--
and then look at a spanning
tree of that shape.
So just cut some of
these edges until you
have tree connectivity
among those squares.
Every tree has at least two
leaves, except in the fall,
but every mathematical tree
has at least two leaves.
Like this is a leaf, if I cut
here this would also be a leaf.
Leaf is a degree one vertex.
So that's a square that
only shares one side.
So pluck off that leaf,
remove that square.
The resulting n minus 1
square is, by assumption,
can be made by this hinged
dissection with two times
n minus 1 pieces.
So now we just have
to attach this guy on.
And here's a figure for
that down at the bottom.
This is the same
thing for triangles,
and polyabolos are
in the upper right.
So you have some existing
hinged dissection,
you don't really
know what it's like,
and you want to add
this leaf back on so it
shares one edge with one guy.
Now this guy could
be oriented this way,
or it could be
oriented this way,
but it's the same by reflection.
So let's say it's
oriented this way.
We know the square is made up by
two half-squares, by induction,
and so we know that
there's a hinge here.
Now this hinge connects to
some things, in this case,
to some t prime.
It could be here,
it could be up here.
And all we do is
stick s on here.
Now s can rotate.
We have our solution
for one guy,
and there's two different
orientations for him.
We're going to choose
this orientation
because it puts this
hinge right there.
And so once we do that,
normally this would be a cycle,
and this thing would be
a cycle through here,
but we just redo
the hinges in here
so that the cycle gets bigger.
And the important
thing to verify
is that the orientations
to the triangles
are the same, just like the
hinged dissection picture
I showed.
We always go from the base
edge to the next base edge,
to the next base edge of these
right isosceles triangles,
and all the triangles are
on the outside of the cycle.
So we actually construct a
cyclic hinged dissection.
Then at the end you could
break it and make it a path.
And this one is even slender.
Remember, right triangles
are slender, barely.
You can look at all
the inward normals.
They hit the base edge.
So this will even
move continuously
if it's an open chain.
For closed chains we don't know.
So that's polyominoes.
Polyaimonds are similar.
Pretty much the same thing.
You just-- in this
case, you might
have hinges on both sides, but
you rotate this thing so one
of the hinges lines up, and
you just reconnect the hinges.
And it's not hard to
show you can always
do that, the hinges
will never cross.
And this proves that
these folded states exist,
and then we use the slender
stuff to do continuous motions.
Actually, when this
paper was written
we didn't have slender
adornments back in '99,
even in 2005 when the
journal version appeared.
So it's only now that we know
that motions are possible by,
in this case directly, in this
case with some refinement.
So I thought that would
just be fun to see.
You can do some
other crazy things.
So this is a hinged dissection
from any four-iamond.
So this is four equilateral
triangles joined together
to any four amino.
This is a tetris piece.
It's essentially a
superposition of this idea
with-- you see in here,
these four lines make
the hinged dissection
of Dudeney,
from 1902, from an equilateral
triangle to a square.
And with some extra
stuff added in-- this
is maybe a foreshadowing
of the idea of refinement,
although we didn't really
realize it at the time.
We want to add some
hinges so that we
have hinges on the midpoints
of the edges instead
of the corners.
That turns out to be a bit
more efficient in this case.
So we add some hinging,
still hingeable individually,
but now we have
hinges at the corners
and so-- at the
midpoints, and we'll
have the same
property over here.
And it allows you to
hinge these together.
Actually, here it looks like
some of them are at the corners
not the midpoints.
So it's a bit messy.
In general, we can prove
if you have any shape
and you want to make
poly that shape-- so
let's call this
shape x, you want
to make polyexes-- you can do it
as long as the copies of the x
are only rotated and they're
joined at corresponding edges.
So if you check, this guy's
just been rotated 180 degrees.
In general you can join
these things together
at matching edges.
And the basic technique
is just subdivide
the thing, triangulate, draw in
the dual of the triangulation,
and then connect to the
midpoints of the edges.
And you can show,
basically, instead
of the hinged
dissection going around
like this you can just
make it go around like this
and come back this way.
And if you check the sequence
of pieces they could visit,
it's identical if you
go around this way
or if you go around this way.
And that's enough to show
that any folded state is valid
With the triangles
and the squares
we're essentially exploiting
the symmetry of these pieces.
So you can rotate them
to make them compatible.
Here they're forced to be
compatible by assuming we only
join matching edges.
So that was the
2D polyform paper.
You can see Frederickson
was one of the authors.
In 3D, here's easy way
to generalize that.
If you take, for
example, a tetrahedron,
a regular tetrahedron, you take
the centroid and cut everything
to the centroid.
And you end up cutting
your tetrahedron,
it has four sides, into four of
these more slender tetrahedra.
And then you take four of
them and join them together
in this way.
You do have to be
careful in the way
that you join them
because, again,
on every face we want to
have an incident hinge.
So we've got to
take care in the way
that you hinge together to make
sure that that is the case.
But it's also cyclically hinged.
This gets joined to that.
And basically, the same
inductive proof works.
You just pluck off a leaf, show
that you can turn the thing so
that one of the hinges
aligns with the inductive
construction, and then
just join the hinges
across instead of
within the cycles.
So pretty easy.
What are we talking about?
Hinged dissections
software, I guess.
Those would be fun
things to implement.
They've never been
implemented, and especially,
to see them folding.
I thought I'd show
you a little bit
about hinged
dissection hardware,
different ways you could
make them physically real.
This is kind of
mesoscale I'd call it.
This is at one centimeter
bar, so not super tiny,
but I think this could
scale down quite a bit.
We have a Petri dish here
with some liquid in it,
if you could read up there.
Maybe this is the
coolest example.
We have a square made
up of four pieces,
and you add a little bit
of salt to that liquid
and it pops into the equilateral
triangle configuration.
So it's sort of spontaneously
folding, hinging.
Essentially these pieces
are slanted a little bit
and they prefer-- one weighting
causes them to fold one way
but when you add the salt they
end up flopping the other way.
You could see they're a little
bit inexact because of that,
but pretty awesome the
kinds of hinged dissections.
You can get them all to
actuate even without much room
to do so.
This is done at Harvard, George
Whiteside's group, chemistry.
Kind of related, it's not
exactly hinged dissections,
but I feel like it's
the same spirit,
is this idea of DNA
origami, it's called,
where you take one
big strand of DNA
and you force it to fold
into a particular shape.
Here we're folding
it into a happy face.
The way that's done
is you add in a bunch
of little pieces of DNA.
So this string, basically,
has a-- this DNA strand
has a random string
written on it basically,
and you identify, oh, I want
these guys to glue together.
So you take this piece
of the random string,
and this piece of
the random string,
and you construct a piece of
DNA that has both of those,
like a little zipper to
cause those to zip up.
You do that all over the place.
And there's now automatic
tools to do this,
it's really easy to
make DNA origami.
It, basically, always works.
There's a limit to
how big this thing can
be because the main strand
here is a single piece of DNA,
and those are hard to make
super big, at least currently.
But you get some really
nice happy faces and mass
produce them.
Hundred-nanometer scale.
It's kind of like
hinged dissection
because that strand
of DNA is moving,
it's actually more
like a fixed angle
chain, kind of like
a hinged dissection.
And we're essentially
using here universality
of hinged dissections
of something
like polyominoes,
though the shapes
are a little bit more awkward.
And they've made a
maps of the world.
You could do two-color patterns,
make snowflakes, the word DNA,
and crazy stuff.
So it was started by Paul
Rothman, though a lot of people
do DNA origami these days.
Cool.
Next paper I wanted to show
you-- this is fairly recent--
and it's about getting
continuous motions,
in particular, in 3D, of
hinged dissection-like things.
So here we have
a chain of balls.
These are more like
ball and socket joints.
So you can maybe see
them better here.
There's a member going
in from the green guy
into the center of the red
guy, and there's a slot,
and the red guy can fold
around the-- or the blue guy
can fold around the red guy.
And the question is,
OK, this is great.
You can prove universality,
you can make any shape.
You just subdivide your
dog, or whatever, into two
by two by two
squarelets and then
we know how to
connect those together
to make a nice Hamiltonian
cycle that visits everything.
But can you actually fold
a chain of balls like this
into that dog?
And the answer is always yes.
Essentially, you feed a
big string of these balls
into-- that's actually what's
happening in this animation
here, although it's a little
hard to tell-- you're feeding
in, say, at one of the legs,
one of the extreme points
in some direction,
this chain of balls.
And as they go in they just
start tracking along the path.
And you just need to check that
you can track along the path.
As this guy goes into
a corner, for example,
you can actually navigate the
corner while, at all times,
staying within the tube.
If you can stay
within the tube you
know you won't collide
with the rest of the chain
because this tube is
non self-intersecting.
And so the 2D version
is fairly easy.
This is just circles.
A little trickier to check
that it actually is possible,
with just one turn, with a
U-turn, and with a kind of-- I
don't know what you call
this, not a U-turn--
where you change
in two directions--
two dimensions all at once.
All of these are possible with
this particular mechanism,
whatever mechanism you have.
If it can do this then
you can make anything.
So that's another
way to prove motions
exist for this kind of
polyform special case.
Why do we care about this?
For building robots.
So these are somewhat
different mechanisms,
but I have two
examples built here
at the MIT Center
for Bits and Atoms
over in the Media Lab
with Neil Gershenfeld
and many, many people.
So you get some idea--
this is a fairly small guy.
I mean, the actual
size is about this big.
You see some feet
in the background
to give you some sense of scale.
It's not very many pieces, but
if you made a really long chain
it would really be able
to fold into anything
you want, just servos
to make the turns here.
This is a much larger one.
The right version is folding.
And you get some
idea of scale here,
this is, when it's
fully extended,
144-- should that
be feet or inches?
It's really big.
So a little bit
slower, of course,
because it has to
move a lot more,
and it's also
quite a bit longer.
This is built, in particular,
by Skylar Tibbits here.
So that's the idea of robots.
In general, we
like to make robots
that can change their shape.
We've seen sheet folding
robots, but these
are more chain folding robots
inspired by proteins, and DNA,
and things like that, sort of
big versions of DNA origami.
What's cool about
them is that they
stay connected
throughout the motion.
You can keep your wiring, and
you can keep your batteries,
and whatnot, and your
communication channels
connected in this
kind of scenario.
This is, by contrast, to
more common approaches
to reconfigurable robots.
You have individual
units and they can attach
and detached from each other.
You could see like these
guys picking up blocks,
moving stuff around.
It's definitely cool,
but in practice it's
a lot harder to build
these kinds of robots
because the attach
detach mechanism,
it's hard to get them
to align perfectly,
it's hard to get the
electrical connectivity.
Every piece has to
have a battery instead
of like every 10th
piece, or one battery
to drive everything, or
tethering, or whatever.
You can do some very cool things
and there's a lot of algorithms
around for doing this.
Daniella Rus, here at
MIT, built this robot,
and a bunch of others.
There's also a very
cool theory about these.
I've worked on them.
You can prove, for example,
that all of these models
can simulate each other up
to constant factors in scale.
So you can take your
favorite robot in a molecube
and simulate a crystalline
robot, or vice versa.
And then there's
efficient algorithms
to-- these crystalline
robots, they
can just expand and contract
and detection and attach.
And you can prove that
given two configurations
you can change it from one
to the other up to some scale
factor.
You can even do it
extremely fast in log n time
if all the robots are
actuating all at once.
Anyway, there's cool stuff
about reconfigurable robots,
but the hinged dissections
offers an alternative
where everything stays
connected at all times,
but closely related.
I think that was
the hardware story.
So we go back to our proof
of hinged dissections
and why it works.
And one of the-- I was kind of
surprised I didn't show this
in lecture, but I don't
remember why I didn't.
One missing piece
with-- how do you
go from a rectangle of one
size to a rectangle of another?
You may recall,
we had a triangle,
we triangulated our
polygons so we ended up
with some arbitrary triangles.
Then we cut parallel
to the base halfway up.
You can put this over
here, put this over here,
you get a rectangle of
some unknown height.
And then to make it universal
we wanted to convert everything
into a rectangle
of height epsilon
so that then we could just
string them together--
obviously, the area has
to be preserved here.
If we string together all
the epsilon height rectangles
we've got one super long
epsilon height rectangle.
And then we overlay
the two dissections.
This is how we did dissections.
But how do you do this step
from one rectangle to another?
This is a very old
dissection, at least 1778.
It wasn't published
by Montucla but he's
credited in this
publication, and this
is Frederickson's diagram of it.
So you take the fatter
rectangle and then
you take the longer rectangle
and you-- first, you
make multiple copies of the fat
rectangle, just sort of tile
strip of the plane to the right.
And then you angle the
thin rectangle, slightly.
First of all, you
line up these corners
so the top left corners
line up, and then we
want the top right corner
of the thin rectangle
to lie on this bottom line.
Turns out this always works.
It's not totally obvious but,
essentially, these copies
of the rectangle you can
kind of fold them up.
And when you go off
the right edge here,
you're essentially coming
back on the left edge here.
And then you're going this
way, and you're going this way,
and this little piece is exactly
the same as this little piece.
And from that you
get a dissection.
It's not hinged, but you can
see that this big rectangle has
the tiny piece here, which
conveniently fits right
over there.
It's like a wrap around
in the other direction.
And then this piece-- well,
everything matches up here.
The only other weird
thing is this bottom--
when you go below the bottom
you also wrap around to the top.
And just check all
the pieces match up,
and you've got your dissection.
It's kind of crazy.
You have to check this works
for all parameters, but it does.
And in general, of course, if
you have a very long rectangle
you need many pieces,
relative to the fat one,
but that's essentially optimal.
OK.
For fun-- this is
a general technique
called the piece lie
technique, or superposing
two tessellation of your shape.
You can use that same
technique, for example,
to get the hinged dissection
from a regular square
to the equilateral triangle.
You just angle it right
so that, for example,
this midpoint hits
this midpoint,
and various other
alignments happen,
like this midpoint
falls on that edge.
And if you look at it
right these cuts give you
the four pieces for the square
to-- I guess you can see it
right here, here are the
four pieces of the square.
And if you check,
everything matches up.
You can also make
equilateral triangle.
In this case, it
happens to be hinged.
That doesn't always happen.
It's a little tricky
to tell, maybe,
but with practice
you can see it.
I mentioned, at some point, that
you could take this and turn it
into a table that either has
four sides or has three sides.
One of the annoying
things about the table
is that you need legs
on each of the pieces.
So Frederickson was playing
around with this fairly
recently, in 2008,
and he came up
with this alternative way of--
essentially the same technique,
but you end up
with one big piece
and lots of smaller pieces.
So the idea is you just have
a big leg, or a bunch of legs,
under one piece of the table.
And so this is what the
dissection looks like.
Unfortunately,
it's not hingeable.
But if you add in
a couple pieces
you can make it hingeable.
So at this point, the
universality result
was probably none.
This is actually a lot
easier than the way we do it,
specialized to this
kind of scenario.
This hinges, I think, something
like this-- maybe even
an animation of it?
Yeah.
Drawn by Frederickson.
So you could see a careful
orchestration here just
to make sure that, indeed,
you can avoid collision.
And so that's the
proposed table.
No one has built it.
Another project would be to
build some hinged dissections,
for example this one,
as real furniture.
It would be pretty neat.
I have a couple examples
here of real furniture built.
This is the Dudeney dissection,
a four-piece kind of a cabinet.
It's got lots of shelves.
It looks really practical.
And I don't know the bottom.
It looks like there's a
bunch of wheels down there.
Definitely, you
have to have a bunch
of table legs in this case.
But you can really
reconfiguration it
in all sorts of ways.
The close up.
That looks pretty cool.
It's made by D Haus Company.
Any German speakers?
Anyone know what "haus" means?
Same in English, house.
So they actually built a house.
And I can't tell whether this
is a real building or a very
good computer rendering.
It may be real.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It looks
like a rendering.
PROFESSOR: It looks
Yeah.
At some point later they
have people walking by,
but it could be a composition.
Anyway, it's an idea of
having a house for any season.
You can reconfigure it
dynamically with these tracks.
It's a pretty cool idea.
It would be neat
to experiment with.
Anyway, hinged
dissections in practice.
It's funny to take
a 2D dissection,
but, I think, in
architectural setting
you can't change
where the floor is.
So probably, 2D
dissection makes sense.
There's the real,
maybe real version?
I don't know.
So that was
rectangular rectangle.
OK.
I'm cheating a little bit.
Another question.
This is a very
specific question,
but for step three,
which is where
we did all the action of
rehinging stuff, I said,
number of pieces
roughly doubles.
I meant to say at
least roughly doubles.
So in the worst
case, the point is
that can be at
least exponential.
It definitely can be more
because, in general-- remember,
it looks something
like this-- The point
is, you need at least
two triangles per edge
here because they
need to fit together
to make these little kites.
So you at least double, for
every edge that you visit.
In the worst case,
you visit the whole--
all the edges of the polygon.
So you end up
doubling everything.
But it can be worse
because sometimes,
if you don't have a lot
of room in this corner,
you've got to divide into
lots of very tiny triangles.
I think that probably only
happens towards the beginning.
After you've cut
them small, you won't
have to cut them
even, even smaller.
But I don't know for sure.
The point is, it's
at least exponential.
And this is the more
complicated diagram.
But I claim that you could
get a pseudopolynomial bound.
How do you do that?
This is a little
[? trickable, ?]
and still have time though.
So let me go over the rough
idea, also what the claim is.
So pseudopolynomial bound.
I'm not going to claim this
for arbitrary polygons,
although I think
it's probably true.
What we argue in the paper
is that if the vertices
of the polygon lie on
our grid, then we're OK.
It's just a little hard to
keep track of otherwise.
I will scale things to
make this the integer grid.
And then the claim is
the number of pieces
is polynomial in the number
of vertices, n and r--
r is usually some
ratio of the longest
distance to the
smallest distance.
In this case r is the grid
size, like an r by r grid.
That's like the size of
the overall grid divided
by the size of a grid cell.
So, basically, the same thing.
So, how do we prove this?
The general idea-- so we have
these messy constructions,
and essentially,
we're inducting.
We're moving one hinge, and
then moving the next hinge,
and moving the next hinge.
And essentially, all
of those inductions
are nested inside each other.
You completely refine
to do one thing then
you have to refine to do
the next one in the existing
refinement.
So we have a very
deep recursion.
It's one way to think of it.
Order n depth recursion, so we
end up with exponential in n.
But instead, what we can do is
only recurse to constant depth.
And if you're just more careful
in the overall construction
this is possible.
How?
Let me give you
some of the steps.
You need more gadgets and you
need to follow-- So before,
I said, oh, there's some
dissection out there,
it's known.
You triangulate, you convert
triangle to square, triangle
to rectangle, rectangle to
rectangle, then superpose.
It does the dissection, then
we hinge it arbitrarily,
then we fix the
hinges one at a time.
Here, I want to actually
follow those steps
and keep it hinged dissection
as much as possible.
So we're going to triangulate
the polygons, but in this case,
we're going to subdivide
further and also triangulated
with all the grid
points as vertices.
It's little hard to
draw, but here's a grid.
Let's draw a polygon.
Hard to make a very exciting
polygon, so few vertices,
but maybe something like that.
OK.
If I triangulate this thing
and all the interior points--
there aren't very many interior
points in this example.
Maybe I'll make a
slightly different one.
There's two interior points.
I want to triangulate,
with those
as vertices of the triangle.
So maybe I'll do
something like this.
A couple different
shapes of triangles here,
but they all have the same area.
This is called Pick's theorem,
special case of Pick's theorem.
So here, they're
all a half-square.
Even though this one
spans a weird shape,
it's one-half square of area.
So the nice thing is if
I do this in polygon a
and in polygon be
the triangles--
there's equal number of
triangles of the same size
because they have
matching areas originally.
There's probably a way to do
this for general polygons.
I think this is the only
step that requires grids
except it's also a lot easier to
analyze, this bound with grids.
So it's, I guess, an
open problem to work out
without grids.
OK.
The next thing is we'd really
like a chain of triangles.
Right now we just have
a blob of triangles.
And we can chainify
the triangles.
This is a step
that was-- I don't
know if I showed the
figure last time.
This is what we do to
slenderfy everything.
We have some general
hinged dissection.
I don't know what it looks like.
We just take each
of the triangles,
subdivide at their
in center, cut,
and then you hinge
around the outside.
And you'll get
one-- in this case,
one cycle of slender triangles.
In this case, all we care
about is that it's a chain.
So we have some
general thing here.
We subdivide each
of them like this,
and then you hinge around.
And so now I've got a hinged
collection of triangles for a,
and I've got his collection
of triangles for b.
I'm just going to
do a to b here.
I should probably say that.
Two shapes.
And conveniently,
these triangles
will still have matching areas.
They're all now 1/6,
if we do it right.
So we get a chain of
area 1/6 triangles.
And I have the same
number for a and for b.
So this kind of cool.
Of course, the triangles
could be different shapes,
but I basically have a
chain of various triangles.
They're all the same area-- a
little hard to draw-- for a.
I have a similar chain for b.
And I just need to
convert, basically,
triangle per
triangle from a to b.
So now my problem
is a lot easier.
I have these hinges
which I need to preserve.
That's a little trickier.
This is actually an idea
suggested by Epstein
before the universality result.
It's like, all we need
to do is do triangle
to triangle while
preserving two hinges.
Then we could do
anything to anything.
So we're following that plan.
And now we're going to use
all the fancy gadgets we have
to do triangle to triangle
while preserving these hinges
and not blowing up the
number of pieces too much.
But definitely simpler.
We're down to
triangle to triangle.
Next step.
OK.
Next problem Yeah.
This is slightly annoying.
I said, oh great, these
triangles are matching up.
But I'm not going to be able
to do triangle to triangle
and get exactly the hinges
I want where I want them,
so I'm going to have
to end up, for example,
moving this hinge
to another corner.
So we're going to use
a new gadget, actually,
for fixing which vertices
connect to which triangles.
This is, maybe, not obvious yet
that we need this, but we will.
And we're going to use a
slightly, a somewhat more
efficient version of,
essentially, the same idea.
So we've got a hinge
here, in the middle.
And basically, can't control
where the hinge goes, but it's
supposed to go to
one of the corners.
So we're going to
reconfigure in this way.
So we assume we have
some way of doing it.
And here's the thing, we assume
that maybe this has already
happened to a.
We don't want to recurse
into a because then we
get exponential blow up.
I'm going to have to do this
for every single triangle here.
There's n of them.
That's a lot.
I don't want to
get deep recursion,
I don't want to get
depth n recursion.
But if I cut up in this way, in
fact, I only need to cut up b.
And if b hasn't been
touched yet this is OK.
And then I'll do
it the next way,
and the next triangle,
next triangle,
and they won't interact.
That's the good news.
So how do we do it?
Well, we cut up a little, oh,
what do we call it, kite fan,
I believe, here.
Here there's two kites,
and we get these triangles
to match these two, these
triangles to match these two.
We cut up this little
piece along the side.
And either the green
stays in here-- green
is attached to the
pink or magenta.
So if we keep the green in
here, the triangle stays there.
If we pull everything out--
and there's a little hole
made here to make
that more plausible.
But in reality, we have to
subdivide to get slender.
So if we instead reconfigure
the green to lie along the edge,
and the blue can turn
around here and fit inside
because it has exactly
the same shape,
these two chains are identical,
it can also fit in here.
And then we've moved the
magenta over to that side.
So that's cool.
That works, and it
doesn't touch a.
So it's a slight variation
of what we had before.
And it's good.
So, that's psudeopolynomial,
and they don't interact.
And so we can move
these things however
we need to according to what
step four produces for us.
So this maybe
slightly out of order.
I could have called that step
four, and this step three.
Get to the more exciting part.
Finally, we do
triangle to triangle.
This a little crazy.
I'm going to give you
three constructions that
give us what we want.
And then I'm going to
claim I can overlay them.
This is what we can't do
with hinged dissections,
but I'm going to do it anyway.
So bear with me.
The final gadget will
say how to overlay them.
But let's start with the
relatively simple goal
of triangle to rectangle.
This I already showed you.
And the nice thing about
triangle to rectangle,
this three-piece dissection, is
you can hinge it here and here
and it works just fine.
So that's already a
hinged dissection.
That's the easy step.
Then we want to
take that rectangle
and convert it into a tiny--
or not tiny, same area,
but an epsilon-height rectangle.
Because remember, we
have two triangles,
they're different shapes so
they have different heights.
This one will end up
being half the height,
but it won't match what
we'd get for this triangle.
So I'm going to do steps a and
b for each of the triangles.
And then I have two
epsilon-height rectangles.
And then the challenge is to
convert one into the other.
This is a challenge because
they have hinges on them.
So with dissections you just
overlay these two cut ups.
But hinged dissections, there's
hinges you have to preserve,
we can't do that.
OK.
First part is step b,
which I showed you already,
going from one
rectangle to another.
Here's another diagram of it.
It turns out it's almost hinged.
You can, essentially,
just flop back and forth
and back and forth,
except at the end
you might be in trouble.
So there's one step here,
and depending on parity
exactly this piece of the
rectangle is hinged here.
But I really want
to be hinged here,
so I'm just going to
move it over here.
I have tools for
moving hinges around.
So it turns out, you have
to check that this is safe.
But you just do one hinge
moving, and then you're OK.
So in this case-- this should
actually go a little bit
deeper-- the bottom
figure shows when
you go too deep you can
cut, cut-- and this is just
like the previous diagram
of triangle to rectangle.
You do that at the
bottom you'll be fine.
There's a couple different
cases in exactly the parity
and how you end up.
Three cases I guess.
But in all cases the
rest can be hinged.
You just need this one step
in the middle to fix it.
So most of it is just
swinging back and forth.
So it's almost hinged,
which is good news
because we have tools to make
almost hinged things actually
hinged.
So that's cool.
So basically, we've covered
a and b at this point.
But the last part
is c, or how do
we superpose all these things?
And this is using another
gadget called pseudocuts.
And essentially, you have some
nice hinged dissection already,
and you want to add
a cut and a hinge.
So just imagine cutting
all the way through here
and adding a hinge, I guess,
on the yellow side here.
And somehow, I want
this thing to fold
in all the ways it used
to be able to fold.
So it could fold into a.
But then I also want it to be
able to fold at this hinge,
and eventually fold into b.
And it's complicated,
but again, the same idea.
So we've got these yellow guys,
which normally live in here,
and so yellows is yellow.
These are triangles.
These are triangles
minus triangles,
so they're like little quads.
They have holes just the
right size for the yellow.
These guys have holes
just the right side--
I'm sorry, how does it go?
OK.
I see.
It's purple, then blue,
then yellow, I believe.
So the yellow fits
into the blue-- anyway.
Whatever works.
These guys nest together.
And when they nest together
they fill these little holes.
And then there's matching
patterns out here.
So they all fit.
How does it go?
Actually, sorry, I think
they're all triangles.
This just looks multicolored.
So it looks like
purple here is going
into the cyan one
at the next level.
The yellow guys are
going into the purple.
I see.
So there's a triangle
and a quad here.
Lovely.
And then these guys
stretch across.
Definitely a little
more complicated.
And you lose a factor
of two, or whatever,
but if you apply these
pseudocuts in the right order--
and these are fairly simple
cuttings that we have to do.
We know that these cuts
are mostly a striping.
So if you just apply them in
order you don't get blow up.
I'll just wave my hands at that.
It's a little hard to draw
the picture, obviously,
but that's how it goes.
And that's pseudopolynomial
hinged dissection.
This is why-- it was
intentional I didn't cover it
in lecture because it's
pretty complicated.
There wasn't time.
Any questions?
Last topic is higher dimensions.
Can we get a brief
overview of 3D dissections?
So this is more a dissection
question than a hinging
question, although, of
course you could ask,
does all this work for
hinged dissections?
Pseudopolynomial, we
don't necessarily know.
For straight up proving that
hinged dissections exist,
the claim is-- it hasn't been
written up formally yet--
the same techniques work.
You can take any
dissection and convert it
into a hinged dissection.
But in 3D, it turns out,
dissections, by themselves,
are not so simple, as
a lot of open problems.
Some nice things are known.
So let me tell you
about 3D dissection.
If I want to convert
one polyhedron
p into another polyhedron
q, obviously, the volumes
must be the same assuming we're
doing a reasonable cutting
and not some crazy
axiom of choice thing.
So volumes have to match, just
like for polygons the areas
have to match.
But that turns out
to be not enough.
And this goes back
to a Hilbert problem.
So you may have heard
of David Hilbert.
He wrote this paper of like
23 open problems at the turn
the previous century, 1900.
This is problem three.
It wasn't directly about
hinged dissections,
or about dissections rather.
A little bit convoluted--
it's about some certain axioms
and proving certain things.
But in particular,
he was asking,
are there two tetrahedra
of equal base and altitude,
so equal volume,
which can in no way
be split up into
congruent tetrahedra?
So there's no way to
dissect one into the other.
If that's true it would
show the certain axioms
are necessary and
certain proofs.
And it turns out it is true.
There are tetrahedral of equal
volume where you cannot do
this.
And that-- I don't
have a slide for it--
but this was proved
by a guy named Dehn.
And he came up with something
called the-- well, that we now
call the Dehn invariant.
He didn't call it that himself.
And these things
must also match.
It's called invariant
meaning that no matter how
you cut the things up and
reassemble the Dehn invariant
doesn't change.
And so if you have any
hope of going from p to q,
those two things must match.
And then, Sidler--
so this was 1901,
Dehn proved that this was
a necessary condition.
So like a year
after that appeared.
In 1965, a little
bit later, Sidler
proved that this is
all that's necessary.
So these are
sufficient conditions.
If p and q have the same volume
and the same Dehn invariant,
then there is
actually a dissection.
And he proved it
somewhat algebraically,
somewhat constructively,
I'm not sure exactly.
There's a simpler proof
by [? Jephson ?] in 1968.
And he proved that, actually,
in 4D the same is true.
In 4D you need the
volumes to match
and the Dehn invariants to
match, and that's enough.
In 5D and higher no one knows
what it takes for a dissection.
Pretty weird.
It could be interesting to
study these more carefully.
Let me tell you briefly
about Dehn invariants.
A little awkward unless you're
familiar with tensor product
space.
How many people know about
tensor product space?
A few.
OK.
If you've done quantum stuff,
I guess, it's more common.
I'm not familiar with tensor
product space, but here we go.
Tensor product space.
But I can read Wikipedia
with the best of them.
It's a fairly simple
notion, it just
has somewhat weird notation.
You can do things
like take something x
and write tensor product with y.
And what this means
is, basically,
don't mess with this product.
OK.
It's a product.
Really, this is two
things, x and y.
They're not
interchangeable, they're
in completely different worlds,
different units, whatever.
You can't like multiply them.
They just hang out side by side.
You also can't flip them around.
It's not commutative.
OK.
Fine.
But some things hold.
Like if you take, I don't know,
z and add it to this product,
you do have
distributivity, so you
can get x-- is this-- no, this
doesn't look very correct.
If I have this then you
can multiply that out.
So you get x tensored
with y plus x tensored z.
So that holds.
It also holds on the left.
And the other thing is
that constants come out.
So if we have c times
x tensored with y,
this is the same thing as
c times x tensored with y.
So in the end I'm
going to have a bunch
of these pairs,
these tensor pairs.
And I'm also able to
add them together.
And nothing happens when
you add them together,
they just hang out.
So in general-- you could
also have a constant factor--
so you have a linear
combination of pairs, basically.
Why am I doing this?
Because here's the
Dehn invariant.
Dehn invariant says,
look, with polyhedra
you've got two things-- it's
going to be the x and the y
over there-- you've
got edge links
and you've got dihedral angles.
So look at every edge.
Here's an edge of
my polyhedron here.
It has some length,
which I'll call l of e.
And there's some angle here,
which I'll call theta of e.
Add those up over every edge.
So the Dehn invariant
is going to be
the sum over all edges of the
length tensored with the angle.
AUDIENCE: Isn't an angle a
function of two [? of these? ?]
PROFESSOR: Angle is the angle
between these two planes.
So that's a dihedral angle.
Yep.
So for every edge there's
one dihedral angle.
Just sort of the interiors
of all that angle
there at the edge.
So this is kind of
what's going on.
And these things have to match.
Now it's a little
more complicated.
Sorry, it's not
really just the angle.
Essentially, if you add
rational multiples of pi nothing
happens.
So you actually take this weird
group, all rationals times
pi-- All this means
is if you have
two angles and their difference,
that you subtract them
and you get a rational
multiple of pi,
then those two angles
are considered the same.
So what this is really
saying is I only
care about the irrational
part of pi, roughly.
You add pi over 2, that
doesn't change anything.
Why this thing?
Well if I take an edge,
and for example, I
cut it in half
anywhere, I could cut it
at an irrational
fraction, or whatever,
I will get two
lengths but they'll
be tensored with the same angle.
I didn't change the angle.
And so by
distributivity-- once you
get things inside
the same place.
So in this case, we'll get
two lengths that add up.
They match.
OK.
So as long as you
have matching angles
you can add the
lengths together.
That's what
distributivity tells you.
Similarly, if I tried to cut
this angle in some piece,
it could be an irrational
ratio between the two pieces,
they will have the
same edge length.
And when I have
matching edge lengths
I can use distributivity and
add the angles back together.
So basically, when you dissect,
this thing will not change.
It's a little more
awkward when I cut here
because this was
originally a pie,
and then I cut it
into some pieces.
And this is where you need
the rational multiples of pi
not mattering.
But eventually you can prove
Dehn invariant is invariant.
The harder proof, you can
prove that it's also sufficient
if you have the
matching volumes.
As recently proved
like a few years ago,
2008, that whether the Dehn
invariant of one polyhedron
and another match is decidable.
So there is an algorithm to
tell whether two polyhedron have
the same this thing.
Decidable is a pretty
weak statement.
Natural open
problem is, is there
a good algorithm to do it?
We don't know.
If it does match, is
there a good algorithm
to find the dissection?
We don't know.
These may be easy if you really
understand the proofs deeply.
But at the time no one
cared about algorithms.
At this point, we need to go
back and really understand
how to actually do 3D
dissections so that we could
then do a 3D hinged dissections.
That's it.
Don't forget, orgami
convention is on Saturday.
Should be fun.